[Music]
hey what's up what up what up its we're
here again congratulations podcast it's
the ninth episode and this one's getting
out a little bi got a little bit of some
aggressive tweets and Instagram comments
saying that uh I didn't I did it's late
but it's not late you know why because I
always said that it was going to come
out by Tuesday morning and you'll have
it on the way to work Tuesday so that's
what my promise is to you and guess what
I'm going to break that promise probably
sometime sometimes I'm on the road and
maybe I'll be out there for a long time
and I promise you I will have it up
before your drive to work on Tuesday but
I will most likely break that promise
okay but nonetheless we're here and you
guys are listening right now so you
don't have to complain anymore and
that's awesome
I am back from the road I was in a man I
did Virginia Beach on Wednesday night
which was cool I did then I went to UM
[ __ ] what the hell is it called North
Carolina but it's called Raleigh and I
did that shows there and then I went to
Greensboro North Carolina I went to I
went to Virginia Beach to school I
hadn't been there in eight like eight
years I opened up for jo koy there like
eight years ago and it's a great club
and it was very very very fun show I
can't remember uh the town's nice and
cool but I didn't I didn't get to spend
time sometimes you go to these places
and you don't get to spend time really
uh because you're just kind of tired as
[ __ ]
I flew my flight
by the way my flow is at 5:30 a.m. which
I didn't even know they had flights up
5:30 a.m. and I got in at like 3:30
because no direct flights goes to
Virginia Beach of course and then when I
was in Virginia Beach I did my show and
then I had to go to bed because I had to
go right back to I had to go to would he
call it Raleigh and Raleigh was great
dude this comedy club in Raleigh is
called good nights and it's [ __ ]
awesome man
I mean people should shoot specials
there it's really it's smaller you know
than like a theater but man the crowds
were awesome like I'll definitely go
back there I love Raleigh and it's cool
was like a college town and I was joking
around on stage man dude they have more
runners in that city than I I can't even
believe it it's like the whole [ __ ]
place is a track-and-field
everybody's whizzing by and you're
walking and you feel like a [ __ ]
piece of [ __ ] because you're just
walking and they're running by in like a
UNC shirt and a [ __ ] pink and pink
short shorts and the shows were awesome
and then I went to Greensboro and when I
got to Greensboro I was immediately sad
because if it was first of all overcast
and I don't that was one of those places
where I was like I don't know who lives
here I can't imagine living here there
was like I was like I said to the guy
who was [ __ ] the the owner of the of
the venue I played he picked me up in
his [ __ ] Porsche dude he was is Syd
Jersey in Greensboro do it he came out
by the way I love this guy I've been
texting him but um he picked me up at
the [ __ ] hotel and he pulled up in
his Panamera or whatever the [ __ ] those
cars are called and I was waiting for
like a an SUV or something and he put
pops out with like a chain he's like hey
I'm gonna do the accent because it's
funny he didn't really have it like this
but he was like hey use Kris and I was
like yeah he's like come at and I went
in the car he [ __ ] was SC Jersey
doubt and I was like how the [ __ ] did
you wind up in Greensboro
and you and I was like wait a girl ha
yeah like 24 years ago dude did the
venue but the [ __ ] town is so weird
man I can't believe people live
everywhere and then I got there and the
venue was was kind of cool like it had
like this green rooftop this green room
that was huge and I had a [ __ ] like
roped off [ __ ] for no reason nobody was
there and then when I got to the venue I
was like oh man it was pretty cavernous
and cavernous if you don't know about
comp stand up cavernous rooms and rooms
big ceilings are bad for comedy because
there laughs get drowned out and there's
a little bit big my opener was like I
could tell he wasn't having a good time
on stage and then I went on stage and I
had the [ __ ] best time and I told
Greensboro that I was going to come back
so now I have to
even though place makes me sad I kicked
the guy out though because he kept on
yelling [ __ ] out I kick a guy out in
four minutes like I started a started
doing like telling me to do the drunk
girls bit I was like you guys stop you
gotta be quiet and then he kept going
and doing it I said yo yo security I get
this guy to [ __ ] out of here
everybody started clapping and they
kicked him out and then after the show I
realized that his girl and him fought
this security the girl was scratching
the security and was like [ __ ] you [ __ ]
you and my opener Mike was out there and
she was like you piece of [ __ ]
and I was like I thank God we threw you
out that happened in Raleigh - I didn't
know that people got thrown out people
were like lighting up my Instagram
afterwards I got off stage and people
were commenting on different instagrams
like by the way your security [ __ ]
sucks they threw us out for laughing hey
and no they didn't dude there's a video
that plays in front of a lot of the
Improv I don't think they actually have
any more but it would be like don't
heckle don't take pictures and Todd
Glass's their comedian and he was saying
and everyone who gets kicked out says we
were just laughing and it's true you
don't get hit that for laughing II
absolutely don't get kicked out for
laughing because that's what you're
supposed to do you know you know you get
kicked out for laughing at a comedy club
like you get kicked out of a gym for
running on the treadmill that's how
that's why you ever get kicked out run
now treadmill
at the gym no that's because doesn't
have if you're at a comedy club you
laugh you get kicked out guess what
guess what in an alternate universe
guess what you get a different dimension
because doesn't happen on earth in this
dimension
or is it that you drunk and you're not
gonna remember what the [ __ ] happened
okay I threw him out and thank God hey
also if I throw someone or if someone is
sauna I even throw the people out I mean
throw the first people out if someone
sort out and then you're the kind of
person that [ __ ] comments on
Instagram Instagram [ __ ] you [ __ ] you
piece of [ __ ] your security sucks
you shouldn't go anywhere you should
stay you should stay at your house and
you should even have an Instagram let
alone be out in public so hmm had some
rowdy ones in North Carolina but
whatever uh
flew back today and [ __ ] a connection
was tidy [ __ ] my travel agent gave me
like a 12 minute connection I was
getting so steaming mad the first flight
I was like this [ __ ] guy in a 12
minute connection I'm never gonna make
it to the [ __ ] plane I'm gonna have
to stay in [ __ ] Charlotte I had to
take a flight from Greensboro Charlotte
which is like a 14 minute drive so I hit
the fly they made a fly to get it there
cuz no direct flight obviously from
Greensboro to LA cuz nobody in the world
would ever be traveling from Greensboro
to LA or LA to Greensboro cuz where is
it so I guy rushed onto the second plane
in Charlotte and I walked in you know
was my boarding zone was gone so I was
there and people were waiting there and
somebody goes hey Chris and I was like
what's up man and you know I was just
with my ego I was like oh it's a fan and
then he was like where's Mike and I was
like oh wow he's a big fan even though
it's my opener and then he was I was
like ah he's on his way and then
he says yeah yeah we were in Sarasota we
just made this connection fighters like
oh this guy is a [ __ ] comedian
because he said we uh and I realized I
recognize them and and then I was like
oh I wonder who's open him for because
uh you know I I was just filming someone
else's or down flight I get on the
flight and it's [ __ ] Sinbad who is
like I love I [ __ ] love Sinbad dude
that guy makes [ __ ] is so funny and I
got on and I was like and I was like oh
[ __ ] I'm gonna try and do the thing
we're like you know I'm gonna say hey
because maybe he knows me because we're
both comedians you know but I was like
if I do it and then he [ __ ] he's like
what's up man
you a fan I'll be like s a heart will be
my heart will be a so broken so I
[ __ ] get up there and I make eye
contact with him and like hey what's up
dude it's Chris man it's nice to see ya
he's like yeah good to see you man and
he was like they were they were telling
stories about you uh somebody named some
some name some guy was still as somebody
I should have known I guess he was like
he was telling story about you man I was
like I'll [ __ ] I hope it was okay it was
like hey man it's never okay yes so I
mean you know he was joking and [ __ ] but
I was like you know it was just a course
in bad react it's sin by interaction and
he had a face towel he had the towel he
has on stage when he wipes his face cuz
he's so sweaty he had it on him at the
airport that [ __ ] and he had the leopard
one was amazing dude that's so dope when
someone saw them there even them in the
airport you know it would be like if
[ __ ] Al Pacino is at the airport with
a [ __ ] with a glazed stare look just
like Oh where's my flight you'd be like
ow and he's in like a [ __ ] burgundy
suit where the [ __ ] is my flight that I
would I love it when people are so them
or like if MC Hammer was
it was flight and he was doing the
sidestepping with the baggy pants and he
was trying to get me any was almost late
for his flight so his going only faster
people were screaming go hammer go
hammer go that I would be like ah that's
awesome you know um I was on the plane
they didn't have [ __ ] plugs on the
plane they didn't they barely hey get
rid of your planes from the [ __ ] 1930s
okay get rid of that [ __ ] and who made
this plane
the Wright brothers hand by hand ha
merican Airlines um and this woman was
in front of me and she was [ __ ] so mad
she was so mad and she wanted to talk to
the oh by the way wasn't it American
Airlines who what was the one that
didn't let the litte girl with the
leggings on American I think that I
thought was American with the with the
leggings whatever he's favoring it up
but United oh it was United that's right
cuz key my buddy texted me uh United is
[ __ ] awful okay
and they delay flights all the time and
they kicked someone off for wearing
leggings right that's what they're
saying and my question to United is why
you were people wear leggings anything
you wear at Starbucks you could wear to
[ __ ] who are you the fashion please
hey United when they said hey a girl got
kicked off because she wasn't dressed up
to coding United I immediately thought
oh her tits were out like out-out I mean
out I mean even if somebody walked into
a Starbucks with a bra on you'd be like
that's weird with just a bra you'd be
like it's weird but like I don't know
maybe if there were kids there you'd be
like yo man maybe go put on a top but
like leggings but she had pants on you
got kicked out for wearing pants
United [ __ ] sucks dude I've never
meant anything more than what I mean
right now United [ __ ] sucks they're
run by cats
I feel like [ __ ] cats or there's a
kitty that's the [ __ ] CEO of a United
Airlines and and there are a few cats
under him but also humans and the humans
and the cats sit around the table and
the the main CEO kitty is like on a
chair and they're other cats on the
table and then [ __ ] there are other
humans around and they're like so how do
we run this company better and they all
kind of have to look at the CEO cat
because you know he runs a company and
even the humans think it's stupid but
it's like but it's still the [ __ ] guy
who runs a company even though it's a
cat and then the cattle just be like and
then the yeah I don't know and I know
and one of those would be like I don't
know and then I'll lick his wrist the
cattle lick his wrist and then that's
why they're [ __ ] delayed all the time
[ __ ] you United straight up
hey United turn round
hey United everything's great but why
you facing me you're
summer service implies that right now
you should turn round alright
hey United but dude why is your nose in
the direction facing my nose make our
noses point in the same direction and
turn round dude [ __ ] United United
[ __ ] blows donkey dicks okay it's
horrible
and everybody knows it and if you're a
[ __ ] guy who got all the mileage in
the + and the [ __ ] goldmember's and
you're on the you know United change it
switch it up I don't care if you're gold
status I'd rather fly in a [ __ ] crate
with chickens than United if I knew is
gonna be on time I'd rather fly on a
crate with chickens under the [ __ ]
passenger luggage [ __ ] or whatever
anyone who works at United line up turn
round seriously [ __ ] for real just do
your job
it's weird to be in these hotels um like
I was in three different hotels this
week and to watch like regular TV like
this sounds a little elitist than
whatever [ __ ] are and I don't care like
to not watch I mean not really though
it's not really like you're like to not
watch like like Netflix or Hulu or like
a show and I want to watch it you know
like if you have your house and you're
chilling I don't people but I don't feel
like most people have most people know
it's I don't know how what the [ __ ]
whole how America is probably probably
not probably most people have regular TV
but a lot people just have Netflix and
don't have the [ __ ] TV um but I you
know watch it I watch Netflix or TV or
whatever the [ __ ] but when you but I'll
record this shows like I don't watch my
point I don't watch commercials but when
I'm on the road
you got to turn on a [ __ ] TV and
first of all in a hotel hey hotels how
come when I turn on your TV it takes 12
minutes dude when you turn on a [ __ ]
first of all hate the homepage channel
you turn on it goes like this
and you're still waiting by the way it's
still black and and then you maybe hit
it again I turn on you go to hit it
again and then you turn it off and you
notice because right before you hit it
it turns the red blinker turns on you're
like oh [ __ ] it was just on and then
it's off okay like alright [ __ ]
and then you wait a few seconds cuz I
gotta wait a few seconds to let it Jess
state in the off Ness oh you know that
mean and then so then you're like
alright so this is probably good amount
of time to wait now I'm going to try to
turn on again you turn on again and
you're waiting again and you're like
alright god damn it and then the hotel
channel comes on and it's not it's not
the loudest thing in the world it's
louder than that it's like it'll be a
girl taking off a [ __ ] a shawl or
shits a [ __ ] what have you [ __ ] call
those pool we're [ __ ] [ __ ] things
that girls get like I'm gonna cover my
[ __ ] tits and ass but not really you
could still see him and she's taking one
of those and she dives into a pool and
the music is like ding aiming ding
and it's like here at the Sheraton
you're going to be extremely
uncomfortable when either this tv turns
on because it'll hurt your ears or
someone will call you from because the
phone rings louder than an air siren no
hotel no hotel phone rings this loud
ring that's all so you need you know why
you human is never that is how that it
goes ring that [ __ ] loud and it and
and the TV's turning on and then and
then so I'm watching so I'll always go
to the I'll find out the [ __ ] hey
I'll find HLN because I want to watch
Forensic Files that's the only thing
that that's on I know that's a safe bet
in my road travels because it's on 24
hours of [ __ ] day
HLN should be called the [ __ ]
Forensic Files Channel and that show is
the [ __ ] because it's like candy if you
like that [ __ ] murder [ __ ] it's like
candy and it's always the same guy who
does the voice by the way he died last
year but everybody gets killed with
[ __ ] succinylcholine it's it's always
success it'll Colleen and the guy will
be like they found trace amounts of
success and all Collina and every time
he says it I want to [ __ ] my bed they
found trace amounts of successional cold
lena first of all there's already too
many syllables in successional colleen
and this guy adds a more syllables to
success on all Colleen success and all
Accola Lena and [ __ ] dude someone
could get hit over the bait over the
head with a baseball bat and they'll be
like that what knocked him out was a
bludgeoning to the head I'm out on a
Louisville Slugger that was found in the
basement later
but what killed him were traces found of
successional choline
I feel like they put that [ __ ] in there
they put successful calling in the
peoples of people so they can do the
shell Forensic Files at them and make it
and make it happen
and make it [ __ ] they're like they're
trying it like the makers of success on
Alcoa lien they're trying they're like
you know you got to get this success and
I'll call name drug out there I think it
makes your body go limp or like it's
supposed to pass you out and paralyze
you and if you put too much then you
[ __ ] just stop breathing because your
lungs lungs can't work took a dark turn
there huh ah yeah so anyway next to her
bad there was green liquid
it was Lacroix with traces of
succinylcholine they found trace amounts
sometimes the guy will just go to a
different planet on his [ __ ] they
found trace amounts of successional
Collina why is he [ __ ] Optimus Prime
all of a sudden roll out Autobots let's
go time to fight Megatron he's been
killing everyone with succinylcholine
[Laughter]
yes
lasers can stun them but what we need to
get them with are trace amounts of
successional choline oh hey trance
transformer errs more than me is the I
Autobots and Decepticons roll out yah oh
he he's just a needle bring him
[Music]
he transformed into a needle bring him
we're all out a needle full of
successful : no autobots and decepticons
and Autobots and all of us and
Decepticons reow that guy died last year
who did the voice I [ __ ] he died last
year and I looked him up and I will I
looked him up on YouTube about the [ __ ]
because I was like I just typed in
successional : and his person came up
obviously and the first thing that came
up for real though was I forget his name
the voice of forensic file it was a
video to thing called whatever his name
was and then in they'd had a - and it
said the voice ah imagine being so dope
at your job that they call you what like
you used like to do your job like if you
were a [ __ ] mover somebody called you
arms this guy's name was the Dakota the
voice and even his regular voice was
like that they were like so what's
you're getting your inspiration and he
was like trace amounts of
succinylcholine ah um so I watched that
Forensic Files but the one thing the one
thing that you have to do about watching
those TVs Peter Thomas was his name is
regular name Peter Thomas you know
definitely in the witness protection
program
definitely because he [ __ ] murdered
people with successful calling for the
mob they will go to get Peter Thomas
know whatever his name was look at the
voice look at the voice we're gonna you
got a problem
we know something who could deal with it
yeah call him The Voice how's he killed
how's he killed the people it makes it
look like you know he just drank some
Lacroix
hurts your head over the what he does is
he hits you over the head with a
baseball bat
that's not what kills you know what
kills you just place the stuff called
[ __ ] succinylcholine successional
gone and then he [ __ ] got caught by
the FBI and had to relocate to wherever
they [ __ ] they record the Forensic
Files which I guess is probably in
Burbank and his name is Peter Thomas now
and he's got little kids and their
[ __ ] uh they sound the same
like baby [ __ ] their baby voices but
you got to watch commercials that's the
thing about that's what I was trying to
get at you got to watch commercials um -
[ __ ] uh if you're going to watch TV at
a hotel because I don't have DVR or
whatever one time I was at one TV and a
head net but I was at one hotels that
net had Netflix I was like is this the
future um
but you got to watch commercials and and
you gotta watch commercials and it's
[ __ ] Shh yo there let me just say a
blanket thing here and I you know I saw
a commercial that made me laugh maybe
the other day maybe I did maybe to make
me laugh but I won like this but hey ad
guys and commercial guys and people who
are making the commercials step your
goddamn game up they're awful the only
ones that are not awful are the ones
that are [ __ ] like local commercials
that you can watch because they're so
bad but at least you're like oh oh these
are entertaining you know what I mean
you're watching like I can't
there's a real person that but like
don't do the [ __ ] went wimp
I'm tired of washing windows and doing
laundry meet me honey boy only only one
going whoops [ __ ] all over the place
guess we gotta use Windex next time
Nene [ __ ] you [ __ ] you after watching
that I want to drink successional
Collina dude commercials are [ __ ]
terrible man they're [ __ ] terrible
when I'm driving there's got that laughs
in the beginning my friends boy you know
my kids came home the other day [ __ ]
that laughs nothing is that funny there
are things more funny and less funny but
if you're laughing this hard at
something
you're a [ __ ] Jim Carrey character
okay nothing's that funny crackers there
why are they so many crumbs honey there
he goes again no success at all Colleen
drink it if you're one of us [ __ ] you
with that laugh I hate it
step your [ __ ] game up if you're
selling what are you gonna sell a
t-shirt [ __ ] just hock it dude dude
if there was a commercial that came on
TV and it was like t-shirt it was just
some [ __ ] fat Italian guy just like
t-shirts t-shirts for sale get your
t-shirts go get them at Ross you got
t-shirts at Ross I'd [ __ ] fly too
Ross I'd go I'd buy all the t-shirts up
because I'd respect that [ __ ] buy
t-shirts do that some guy some weirdo
instead you get some [ __ ] guy with
glasses on that's kind of good-looking
that's not really good-looking but he's
definitely got like frizzy hair and like
a beard a little bit kind of describing
myself but uh and he's like added dinner
and something goes wrong and he's like
check plays and I'm supposed to [ __ ]
laugh at that and then go run out and
buy [ __ ] you know LensCrafters
hey dick no make it better make the
commercials better dude if you're gonna
have me watch and you know what hey
guess what the Super Bowl commercials
are [ __ ] atrocious - I know I'm the
[ __ ] minority here and I know people
by the way if you're the kind of person
that's like I watch the Super Bowl for
the commercials here comes a fierce [ __ ]
you [ __ ] you alright watch the watch the
Super Bowl for the Super Bowl
also don't watch Super Bowl okay but if
you're the [ __ ] kind of janky ass
[ __ ]
that sits on the couch and is like oh
good the commercials by welcome to my
house
now leave dude I just drives me nuts uh
so yeah same thing with sponsored ads
unlike a online it's funny - some of
them say sponsored and uh and they and
like we know you know if I got a [ __ ]
Starbucks in my hand on Instagram you
better believe Starbucks is [ __ ]
paying before although maybe not unless
I love it but but yeah don't did why why
does
have to be corny why does it have to be
corny that's what I don't get I don't
get why it has to be corny why can't you
just say this is the product you want
you buy this you buy it hey buy it get
me to do it I'll do it I'll do it I
don't want to really be on commercials
but I'll do it if you let me take it
tied
how about tied let me do your [ __ ]
commercials me me I do it I do the whole
thing I direct it I write it I don't
even show up I wear what I want to wear
I got my beard the length I want to have
it and I got my hair the way I want it
with no [ __ ] makeup or touch-up or
[ __ ] and I sit there in a chair and
I say hey you wanna get your clothes
clean you get tied that's what you do
all right
yeah you can get the other products but
don't get tied and that's it that's the
commercial even in 30 seconds you know
that you know how [ __ ] weird and good
that would be it would be good yeah you
might lose like [ __ ] some people in
Des Moines or some [ __ ] but all of a
sudden you're the [ __ ] weird old
brand and yeah you see what tied dude
did oh yeah get [ __ ] Greg Kinnear to
be like I wash all my underwear with
tie-dye wash on my pants with tide I
washed all my shirts with tide I watch
everything with tide have him say that
those four lines that's it that's the
commercial he's not funny about it he's
just being serious greatest commercial
I've ever seen I was just I just made a
better commercial than any [ __ ]
commercial I've seen in [ __ ] years
and you can say that's conceited but
it's not it's just [ __ ] commercials
or
travesties you know what they're like
they're like the scene in [ __ ]
Jurassic Park or Jurassic world when
[ __ ] Chris Pratt sees that big-ass
t-rex and he's like oh [ __ ] that's what
I that's what I [ __ ] feel when I see
a commercial ah [ __ ]
don't make him you don't need a team
[ __ ] your team ah you don't need a team
to make a [ __ ] commercial you need a
[ __ ] person Hey
you making a commercial or you the
Jaguars
Hey I have a question at agencies are
you making a commercial are you trying
to sell a product or are you the Mets
because if you're not the Mets don't be
a team yeah man
drives me nuts owes it sponsor cons I
was on Instagram the other day hey man
uh so all of a sudden DJ Khaled's baby
is the [ __ ] number one thing not
amazing this guy [ __ ] has a squirty
boner and a chick and a baby comes out
and now the [ __ ] baby runs the
internet if I got to see another picture
at DJ Khaled's baby by the way great
have a baby be happy about it awesome uh
but the Jay Khaled said his baby was a
producer not
what's he producing vomit and cries na
na producer oh he's going to produce
music cool does the music sound like
this oh no
then it's he's not a producer okay
dude so baby so baby
it's a [ __ ] infant you can't wipe
your ass he can't produce music some
rule that's my rule
yeah I mean yeah it's funny I get it I
get what DJ Khaled's doing
I [ __ ] didn't think I honestly think
DJ Khaled if there's a genius on social
media it's him the guy's unbelievable
and honestly the the tracks he produces
some of them are [ __ ] hot fire dude
sometimes he does it and he's like
another one and I'm like you know what
actually another one another one baby
baby's gonna come out come baby's gonna
be like another one that's gonna be the
first [ __ ] words
now there Wow DJ Kells gonna be like
here's a cookie and the baby's gonna eat
it and then the baby's gonna be like
Maldor Wow hey oh by the way are they
making [ __ ] uh
The Lion King with real lions that's
what I heard
somebody said live-action Lion King
that's gonna end in murders and deaths
Jon Favreau's directing Lion King live
action
somebody said live action not cartoons
not CGI I mean come on dude does like an
gladiator when Russell Crowe was like
when they were saying a Russell Crowe
that he shouldn't play he shouldn't play
soccer on his off days of gladiator
because they don't want to risk him
getting injured injured and he was like
you go May fine with [ __ ] lions or
New Zealand accent ever
isn't that where he's from I don't know
you get we fought with lions you worried
about me kicking a ball around I don't
know the difference between Australia
accent in New Zealand sorry
sounds good
it's healthy soda drinking it yeah
The Lion King with real lions is like
just make this haven't be CGI it's got
to be CGI it must have been wrong it
must have been wrong
it can't there's no way they are gonna
have like two lions and [ __ ] and then
just CGI the mouths I guess I guess they
could do that but that seems like a
[ __ ] thing that they would do in 1991
with Steve Guttenberg I'm surprised if
John far was going to do that [ __ ]
um but [ __ ] I'll say it I mean lion
Kings awesome Lion King is one of those
things that is is very awesome that
people though people like to pretend
like they like it more than they
actually like it and I love lion
I like liking it's a great movie but you
know when I got to hear some [ __ ]
chick that's like 28
oh they're remaking The Lion King I just
like I want to [ __ ] eat a whole bunch
of donuts you know just so something
else is happening it's like annoying
it's a it's a you know what I mean
they acting like it's curing cancer or
some [ __ ] like it's great it's [ __ ]
AM it's great but it's a movie
there's [ __ ] like that that people do
though there's like the thing that comes
up that I'm in Lion King obviously is
way past you know I mean the would that
come out in [ __ ] 90-some but uh um
the new thing is like is like that it's
actually kind of let me actually talk
about this because I ate some the other
day and I keep trying with this [ __ ] but
kale I keep trying with kale and it hey
you know what it's [ __ ] bad okay I
don't give a [ __ ] what you put on it put
on [ __ ] vinaigrette put on [ __ ]
the ranch dressing I don't give a [ __ ]
put on skittles it [ __ ] tastes like
my end table kale sucks okay
Kayle [ __ ] sucks alright and people
like to flip out about kale and I don't
know how it is in the middle of country
but in LA and in New York there's these
[ __ ] kale places popping up or
whatever the [ __ ] would you like it with
kale
I don't know you have anything with
flavor instead I just it's not good you
get the brown rice get the [ __ ] um
even get the quinoa that's fine but kale
is [ __ ] [ __ ] tastes like toilet
paper and and I don't like when the
[ __ ] when the people get on the
bandwagon and is like oh yeah that's a
thing now it makes me and I tried with
it because I know it it's healthy but
also they make it seem like it's so
healthy that like it will [ __ ] like
they make it seem like like it's so
healthy that you're gonna [ __ ] like
you you you can like it'll help you not
get like it'll cure cancer that's how
they feel make you like wow you know
also though if you got some HIV some
kale that's not what it is it's just
it's just [ __ ] it's it's good for you
but people go overboard with this [ __ ]
and that I want everybody to calm down
about it okay that's what I want I want
everybody to calm down about it you know
because guess what I'd rather be a
[ __ ] bowl of chocolate than that
that's what it is when you start acting
like a bollock ale is better than a bowl
of chocolate that's when you gotta
absolutely turn round
what did i tweeted about this today
earlier I saw it on Twitter I saw two
things on Twitter man one was which one
should I start with one was one was the
[ __ ] I'll start with the one I first
did the [ __ ] i retweeted this thing
about how they made a female somewhere
they made a female quote-unquote traffic
light and either working on it or
they're doing it or they did it or
something and the light is a [ __ ]
body with a dress on instead of the
regular guy walking with the two legs
and the arms apart it's a female there's
a female one now now the the thing that
first of all what I will love is there
is somebody in the world some man in the
world that will see that and literally
think oh okay well the females are
crossing now I should stay here and and
and I'm not I know it's funny but that
will happen with some [ __ ] [ __ ] and
that is great okay that's the upside of
it is that you get to understand that
the people there is going there will be
probably more than once some guy
somewhere that sees that and things and
goes to walk in the things away hold
onto only females get to walk now
legitimately that's the upside all the
other things about it are dumb is [ __ ]
downsides okay hey don't change the
goddamn traffic light there's bigger
problems in the [ __ ] world
number one and that's the most obvious
one but number two how did they not
understand that if they say oh these are
for female now and they put a dress on
it that that's offensive now they're
saying oh because women wear dresses and
you got to wear a dress if you're a
woman
plus men wear dresses you [ __ ] idiots
they [ __ ] themselves harder they
turned around themselves and just sat on
a [ __ ] rod there wasn't even someone
else involved there wasn't even somebody
that was like turn round they were just
like I guess I got to turn round now and
sat on a [ __ ] lamppost dude
that's real dumb these [ __ ] idiot
you know and those are the kind of
people that were like well you know
everyone's a snowflake [ __ ] or
whatever the [ __ ] such a dumb [ __ ] thing
and then I tweeted something else about
how Wonder Woman what the [ __ ] was it it
was a Wonder Woman the movie Wonder
Woman the new one has a poster out and
she's like swinging her sword and she
doesn't have a [ __ ] armpit hair and
she's it's they're like she's from an
island she would have armpit hair Wonder
Woman's lack of armpit hair sparks
feminist debate
with palpable excitement surrounding the
films released the latest trailer which
can be viewed below as spark new
controversy through careful analysis the
Internet has exposed a perhaps not so
wonderful aspect of DC Comics newest
incarnation of the classic girl power
super heroine she has no armpit hair
that's the actual [ __ ] paragraph
while the moment lasts all of a
millisecond not to mention the reason we
can see her armpits is because she's
throwing a truck over her head like a
rag doll it's a millisecond that has
heated that has set off a heated debate
Wow
that's hilarious it's not enough that
first of all she's superhero she doesn't
exist she threw a [ __ ] truck over her
head the weird part about that is not
that she doesn't have hair under her
armpit it's that she's an alien
and she flies around in an invisible jet
what are they mad at if she had armpit
hair then what it's a [ __ ] cartoon
they're making a cartoon literally look
at the quote she's not going
she's an app and was a amazonian it's
not going to be like real Amazon's we
always try to make everyone happy but we
can't that's what a also she's a demigod
they're saying so how do we know maybe
they're born without hair right that's
what they say in this article the
article is NYT live dot and New York
Times com I guess it's an it was in the
New York Times or some and there are
people that are like what the [ __ ] you
shouldn't you know you shouldn't do
imagine imagine seeing that a first of
all it's for a millisecond for sure like
there's no way there's a close-up of her
armpit in the trailer in the movie
imagine seeing that whole trailer with
all of the fantastic [ __ ] that's going
on she's thrown a truck over a head I
mean you know she's awesome she's
action-packed she's kicking ass beating
the [ __ ] out of people she's beautiful
she's [ __ ] whipping around probably
Batman and Superman are in the goddamn
trailer because they can't make a
superhero movie without making more
superheroes in it and and and to [ __ ]
see that for a millisecond and then get
heated and then get heated and not and
first of all to even see it but then to
be like not then not to be like ah [ __ ]
it [ __ ] she's throwing a truck and
then after because that was the trailer
of the movie so you sit in the movie er
then you watch the movie you went to see
then you got home and still had the
[ __ ] tweet about it I am NOT
my political beliefs in this at all but
that is why Trump won that's why he won
I'm not saying he should have he
shouldn't have I'm not gonna talk
political on this [ __ ] podcast but
that's why he won sir if you're Madi one
eeep yeah you're the [ __ ] that's it
man that you did that stop - uh I don't
know uh somebody uh got mad at me for
[ __ ] I did a joke on an incorrigible
my last Netflix special um about
someone's fat in the story I was telling
she's like she was fat now I know you
know don't get upset but she was fat
some people are fat and she was fat I
didn't make her fat she was you know and
I didn't I don't remember what I said
specifically but somebody tweeted the
other day Wow Chris D'Elia makes fat
jokes in his special legging I didn't
really I just said that and then
somebody was like you you know I was
like I was like yo I got to make fun of
everybody equally like I don't give a
[ __ ] I don't think about it when I do it
I just do it your comedian you just
[ __ ] do it you make fun of the person
and you got to have the Liberty to do
that because that's our job
if you don't do that then the comedy
becomes [ __ ] less than and so I wrote
back I got you got it I just make fun of
whoever you know and then the lady was
like [ __ ] crackers or some [ __ ] and I
was like oh racist cool and then [ __ ]
she was like I it's a
you can't be racist against white people
and I know this argument I know this
argument I know it this is like Oh has
has anyone held you back from a job
because of being called a cracker I get
it I get the [ __ ] argument I
understand but you can hate a group of a
race and if you hate them then your
races I'll give a [ __ ] what people say
alright that's what it is
you know yeah in my opinion there can be
a race
you can be racist against a [ __ ]
white person because if you hate white
people you [ __ ] racist that's it ah
you want to say no racism doesn't exist
like that against white people fine but
I don't I don't know if I believe it you
have to [ __ ] convince me a little bit
harder than that then just calling me
cracker and saying you can't be [ __ ]
racist and then people were tweeting me
back just these social justice warriors
I fail to see the racism in this that
you called you cracker have you ever you
mm-hmm and I should know this
this is Twitter you know these [ __ ]
jerk-off [ __ ] behind their
keyboards just type in you can't [ __ ]
write your opinion if your [ __ ] dicks
out in your [ __ ] chair in your TV
room you know on your laptop that's the
rule okay
people are so [ __ ] sensitive it's
very weird because most of the people
don't really give a [ __ ] they just think
it's the right thing to do and that's
[ __ ] poison dude do it don't do it
unless you [ __ ] mean it you know I
understand like gotta hate talk about
this [ __ ] it's so annoying anyway
but like privilege and all that [ __ ] I
get it white privilege I get it no I get
the argument but like mean mean what
mean it you know what I'm talking about
like mean it if you're gonna [ __ ] if
you're going to say if you're going to
say oh if you believe Oh
people shouldn't people should not
abortion should be legal
tweeting it isn't enough don't [ __ ]
tweet it don't tweet it just [ __ ] do
something about it instead if you're not
gonna do anything about it then don't
[ __ ] do anything about it
just sit down cuz that's what everyone's
been [ __ ] doing for years and years
and years and years and just cuz you
have a goddamn computer doesn't mean
you're the [ __ ] president does this
make sense I don't even know I don't
even care to be totally honest that's a
real problem with me I thought it was a
sociopath a little bit because I had
trouble caring about stuff and I took a
test and it said I wasn't so I'm all
good the test was on the Internet
I just don't like uh I don't like these
[ __ ] I don't like these fake-ass
[ __ ] like you know I like
listening to Bach I don't like these
fake-ass [ __ ] can stay if I guess
[ __ ] you know have some [ __ ]
whatever it is I don't know but I I'm
running out of steam here I'm tired and
it's [ __ ] I just got back from
whatever North Carolina uh and I think
I'm done oh I could look at the pocket
look at the thick - I wonder if the guy
game to this system today I wonder if
the guy [ __ ] gamed the system on the
the hashtag a matte girl
Matt Gwyn that's his name and his
hashtag did or is a what he call it
handle his Quinn matte so that's fine
that's why all he could get is or it was
a Mac win what's that that intro/outro
Sonya play on congratulations play it's
by mr. green I use him a lot he did my
last incorrigible special he did my
first Comedy Central special he does all
the intros he did a the Chang Smith
album if you don't know what Chang Smith
is Google chanc Smith he's great he has
a lot of he does he's done a lot [ __ ]
better than that I'm a joke but he's
[ __ ] killer so
that's that's your answer I got another
one here from Eric underscore Anson II
he goes by hey Krista Leah did you get
any of the new air maxes and what are
the essential sneakers to go on tour
with I I love air max I've been more of
a adidas guy lately and I wear these I
don't know on tour I don't bring my
shoes because they're gonna be able
[ __ ] dirty I just bring I have these
converse
so that's my like tour [ __ ] sometimes I
bring the black Jordan ones there's
Simon the cyber Mondays I like those a
lot
I like Jordans a lot still Jordans and
Adidas I like the nmds some of the
Reeboks I like I like Reebok some of the
Reeboks um and that's what I wear pretty
much um those are my my my go twos now
I'm a look at this more here
congratulations pod this is funny
somebody asked me about DJ Khaled's
[ __ ] baby
Oh update on that member last seed Moroz
talk about Leo my French friend I
[ __ ] texted him like twice I
literally just texted him because people
were coming up to me at in North
Carolina like hey what's up with Leo I
was like I think I feel like II was a
big hit look hey sauce bro they were
saying sauce bro and I first I was like
what the [ __ ] you sang and then as I was
the [ __ ] thing Leo texted me I texted
[ __ ] Leo because first of all I want
to hang out with them and second of all
he so yesterday I wrote hang this week
by the way he's a gangster dude cuz he
leaked he it was on it says red and he
didn't write back he doesn't give a [ __ ]
that's so French to leave someone on red
and then today when I landed I was like
this [ __ ] [ __ ] didn't text me
back so I wrote I tried this I literally
thought this work I wrote saw Z a
question I didn't write back we didn't
read that one yet so maybe he's doing
some French [ __ ]
probably eating a baguette or robbing a
painting um yeah so I'll let you know
what happens on the adventures of Leo um
alright this guy writes his name is Jael
on it
swag lives matter which is very very
[ __ ] stupid and also pretty goddamn
offensive handle definitely change it
for sure yo Chris Aleeah just trying to
game the system here check this little
gem out real quick and then the
screenshot of somebody who tweeted just
a friendly reminder that you should call
your animals by gender-neutral or
multiple pronouns they can understand
ken was in capital and yes there's
another tweet it is it's possible for an
animal to be trans your cat having a
penis does not gotta stop I'm sorry I
gotta stop reading that I almost [ __ ]
all over I just don't I don't have time
for that you're a goddamn [ __ ] parrot
okay you're not trans you're not trans
okay
you're not trans if you have wings
all right you crawl yeah and got worried
about can you fly in the air you're not
concerned with gender-neutral
multiple pronouns um here's a good one
Mario part two note pay at bf5 and your
t you're teetering on the change it
you're teetering on a chain you're
teetering on getting a change it but you
didn't get a change it because I
actually think um be be BFF 5 is
probably like maybe I mean some gaming
the system tonight what's your least
favorite thing about LA that's a good
[ __ ] question
god that's a good question because I
love LA I [ __ ] love it and I you know
what my least everything about LA is is
when people say they hate LA because
that's another thing like kale they just
jump on the [ __ ] band
Bagon and they're like it's so hard to
make friends here no you're a shitty
person there's a lot of people
everywhere you're not in the [ __ ]
Gobi Desert you can find people and when
there are a lot of people around there
are some good ones so find those and if
you don't you're a piece of [ __ ] and go
to the Gobi Desert okay that's it
diddle in then that's my [ __ ] PSA as
a funny one how much money would it get
take for somebody to get you fly United
Blake Jones music Blake Jones 1997
that's a good name um I I don't know to
be honest if I knew it was gonna be on
time I'm like if there were two flights
the same you'd have to pay me to take
the [ __ ] United one you and I
probably you probably have to be
honestly honest honest answer if if I
had to pay like okay if one flight is
$600 more and both are equal times same
airline United and any other airline
$600 more I would pay the $600 to not
fly United and I mean that [ __ ] United
um so that's a good 600 there you go
I'll answer one more
this is this is well somebody writes
Matthew Heath his name is Smith Smith
Eakins and change it
hey man you dolt you're a [ __ ] adult
I'm look at your profile picture right
now you got a full head of hair which
means your past baby form change it
Michigan's hey man you can type change
it
thoughts on teenage girls calling their
celebrity crushes daddy
yeah that's [ __ ] weird kinda to me
it's also when they what's up with the
Zadi
huh people call me daddy sometimes Sam's
a D instead of damn daddy the [ __ ] is
wrong with everything man Sam's a d see
ya hey am i [ __ ] how old am I when I
say Sam's a D how old do I sound
Sam's a D I sound like my dad trying to
say something like hey who's a Kendrick
Lamar that's how I sound when I say
Sam's a d [ __ ] all right well let's do
one more and I'll leave oh that's a good
one
I often think about this one uhm jion oh
and his handle is jion oh except there's
a one instead of the eye because
obviously Gianna was taken that's funny
that he couldn't get it and so he's like
I'll just pick I'll just pick it the one
[Music]
jion oh is that Italian I think what do
you think about people who put real in
front of their name as their handle
that's pretty [ __ ] annoying
unless now you know what it's even
annoying if it is Kendrick Lamar and you
do need to find the real one because
you'll have the blue check if you just
have the real [ __ ] you know and
[ __ ] rag regular ten
nah don't have that don't have the real
not good not good
um all right look you guys [ __ ] thank
you thank you for listening to the night
you were almost in double digits you
guys we're almost in double [ __ ]
digits getting these episodes done and I
couldn't have done it without my [ __ ]
babies dude you guys see see you later
babies you were listening to the
congratulations the podcast and this was
the first ever ninth episode and we all
did it together babies rate and review
listen before you turn this off or after
you turn it off it really helps if your
rate and review it and I'm being honest
it helps it helps the length of the
podcast the life the life of the podcast
I should say it makes me want to do it
more to be totally [ __ ] quite frank
I'm really busy and I like doing this
now but if you [ __ ] show in love I
like doing it more so help me help you
right help me help you like the [ __ ]
mo is the movie Jerry Maguire all right
I love Samia so [ __ ] thanks for
listening congratulations the podcast
Chris D'Elia check my tour dates Chris
D'Elia calm I'm gonna be in Australia
I'm gonna be in Oxnard California I'm
gonna be all over the place I think I'm
just I'm a book Oakland soon but I got a
lot of places coming up so check my
website tweet me at crystal yeah and
hashtag congratulations pod if you got
your questions that you want me to
answer thank you see ya my babies
[Music]